how's it going bros mate yeah welcome
the hairs madsen today we're gonna play
with go bro don't play with it out bro
so this is kind of part 2 of YouTube
missions and we're gonna sculpture
youtubers and we're gonna guess who it
is if you guess right you get a point if
you guess wrong you have to wear a thong
what if I'm already young what if I'm
already em okay okay that is the demon
from hell
okay what about it's mine okay you're
gonna do so I like it looks like a
turban it looks like a sperm nice just
laying on pad yeah except one one one
one
whoo next one nice your face oh my god I
carry it turned out yeah all they taste
like I remember really salty
really mmm girl then they practice what
is that the hell thing you guess my
first yours is Kevin yeah boy voices
scrunchie that Ben it's nice crunch
answer here is it not a tumor wow I
don't know the sassy man the pretty eye
- one for me because I guess oh damn you
shouldn't get a point for sucking it
doesn't make any sense
he says what is that what is that is
that a demon
saman what is that that's a youtuber now
you watch you I know anymore
yeah alright me again hahaha totally his
head
alright so my name's pre haircut Priya
hey Danny
no actually my I was thinking I was
gonna do Anthony but then I realized it
look more okay oh she doesn't yeah we
cheating no I'm teaching us s so we are
two - because you guess my right yeah
yeah yeah what you're teaching don't get
my fangirls you're so good at these I
know
yeah yeah I think everything we vote -
jenna Marbles ah damn it
I told you mine yours come on
look at the hairpin by the side please
oh oh that doesn't look like this is so
boys am i right oh alright what's the
score three zeros okay
crack me that booty though
creepy hey what the hell you supposed to
be youtuber who has hair like that since
Annie yeah well it looks like [ __ ] hey
Kara I don't know it's our friend
Anthony Padilla ya deal what Anthony
padilha okay well how about this dad
honest this is okay
come on what is this oh um healthy busy
yeah
do I get the point and you don't you
guessed it Oh points is this change
hey let's change the point I'm winning
now I can have a sudden death one this
is worth three points this is my
masterpiece here in this body
what is that oh it's forget gen ed game
ed yes someone is still a boys night
why do I look so [ __ ] I mean so
Callie so I get a point no okay really
okay who's this viral videos
ooh forum I mean Jamie will engage it
and a meta you to Bernie mood so you
lose I mean damn it ray I don't know how
you won
now you're probably on you you can't win
everything in life
remember that kicks now you have a great
one enjoy your day and think about us
Oh
wait I was was telling like I like the
video that that's it I mix them for stay
awesome
in a British day theist